all right moving on to a story that i
think people are going to love
particularly this time of the year uh as
you enjoy the last weeks of summer it's
almost over folks uh barbecues cookouts
family gatherings getting friends
together and for part of the country at
least all that includes the seasoning
called old bay if you're in the
mid-atlantic you know what i'm talking
about old bay has been a pantry staple
in that part of america for eight
decades more than eight decades in fact
but in recent years the spice blend has
also inspired a broader cult following
and found its way into everything from
potato chips which i endorse to vodka
which i'm still learning about major
garrett met the family behind the
beloved seasoning uh and they found out
there's a backstory featuring an
immigrant with a spice grinder
what's inside a can of old bay turns out
there's a lot inside that red yellow and
blue tin
more than just a spicy salty smoky
seasoning blend that's in part because
of ralph brun age 97. well my father
started the spice company in baltimore
in
1939. gustav brun ralph's dad fled nazi
germany for baltimore in the late 30s he
had spent actually 16 days
prior to coming here
in a concentration camp sounds like a
narrow escape we got out
it was a touch and go situation ralph
was 14 when he and his family arrived
with little money and fewer prospects my
father looked for a job and couldn't
find one and ultimately somebody told
him well you've got the equipment here
go get their business right and he did
he bought this mill in 1935. the
equipment was an industrial spice
grinder brought over from germany so
central to the old bay story it is on
display at the baltimore museum of
industry this machine doesn't make it to
america there is no old bay this is true
this is what started old bee seasoning
at the time gustav made and sold spices
mostly to meat packers for things like
sausages hot dogs and bologna his place
of operation was directly across the
street from the wholesale fish market
which existed there at the time in
downtown baltimore and that's how old
bay found its way into the seafood you
eat today fish mongers would buy gustav
spice mix to steam crabs primarily they
used red pepper i used black pepper
mustard celery seeds that sort of thing
ralph eventually took over the company
before selling it to a british firm
spice giant mccormick owns old bay now
this one
not surprisingly around a crab ralph
brun is a maestro no no no you don't do
that correspondent
not so much he may be tolerated in
maryland keep that up for some old bay
is nostalgic woven into mid-atlantic
august of yesteryear it takes me back to
the warm weather takes me back to the
beginning of summer and if you haven't
noticed old bay is seemingly everywhere
these days printed on shoes aprons
bandanas shirts infused into goldfish
hot sauce beer and yes vodka cheers
greg david is ceo of george's beverage
company which took three years to
develop old bay vodka now sold in the
mid-atlantic the first batch produced
600 cases it sold out in 24 minutes
we've done almost 10 000 cases
since the middle of march the same is
true of old bay goldfish also sold out
in record time
did you ever imagine a situation where
this creation of your fathers and your
families would become this sort of
runaway brand that it's become no i had
no idea it would do that and of course i
wish my father were alive today in order
to see those because he was proud of
this was his baby his father would also
want to pay a visit to the charmery in
baltimore where old bay caramel ice
cream is a menu staple that's amazingly
good and i'm not alone you can feel the
peppery tingling i expected it to you
know taste like the old base seasoning
but it didn't have that it was very
smooth actually amid the old bay mania
ralph brun is a voice of reason a
reality check on seasonal spice swooning
can you love this too much i think when
they get carried away with having all
these old bay this time the other that
you're talking about i think it's
ridiculous but that's what they do it's
a seasoning that's all it is ruff brunt
isn't salty he's just seasoned for cbs
morning's major garrett baltimore
it's a seasoning but it seems to go on
everything i can't get over ralph brown
who's 97. it looks really good
his major by the way in those genes you
see major doing this thing major i saw
major garrett using the mallet though on
that chesapeake bay crab you like to
cook a lot well i mean you know i was
obviously in high school years in
maryland i had a lot of experience so
you do know all day i would actually
catch my old crabs you put chicken neck
on on a piece of yarn drop it into the
bay the crabs come up and grab it if
they're the right size you can take them
up boil them up old bay then at the
great part is at the end if you put
paper down on the table you just wrap
the paper up and clean up is done in one
go okay that's it you're a regular old
tom sawyer over here
or martha stewart
or martha stewart i'm trying to figure
out which one yeah